a beloved staple in our community was
completely destroyed in a fire yesterday
the mount charleston lodge is set to be
a total loss the blaze started before
sunrise and took crews from both the
mount charleston and clark county fire
departments to put it out luckily no one
was hurt and dozens of employees at the
mount charleston lodge are mourning
after that loss and yesterday's
devastating fire but they are also now
without a job now the resort just down
the mountain is hosting a job fair for
them victoria saha joins us from mount
charleston as the mountain community
picks up the pieces
the small community here on mount
charleston is slowly rebuilding the
employees over at the lodge don't have
to worry about being without a job any
longer because the resort here on mount
charleston is opening their doors to
them
owner of the resort on mount charleston
deanna crossman flew in saturday morning
to help her neighbors at the lodge any
way she can we just want to work
together you know we're stronger
together she knew the significance the
lodge had on the mountain and employees
who now have nowhere to go
a lot of people work up here because
they don't want to work in the valley
right and it's just different and we're
the only other option and we
with being the only place left we want
to just make sure people had a home up
here if they
they wanted to stay on saturday she
hosted a job fair for those displaced
employees emily was one of them and now
she'll be working at the resort
always amazing every time i come in here
and the restaurant was the same way it's
always a very welcoming environment and
it's so lovely that they would do
something like that for us the owner of
this resort says she's ok being a
temporary home for the displaced
employees until the lodge is rebuilt
again reporting from mount charleston
victoria saha live local now